at first I was just like I I just felt
like you know we had had a conversation
of like let's let's do this right like
this doesn't have to be yep
this doesn't have to be nasty this
doesn't have to be what I've experienced
divorce to look like it got nasty yeah
it did Kelsey ballerini isn't holding
back about her divorce from Morgan Evans
I think he
loves me more at 23.
and I love me more 29. I'm an open book
the two were married nearly five years
after tying the knot in 2017. I I will
always love you for the fact that you
bring me coffee in the morning before I
get out of bed
that's more of a measure of
self-preservation than anything else but
the country singer reveals on the call
her daddy podcast getting married wasn't
exactly on her bucket list after
watching her parents split when she was
a kid okay take me to your wedding day I
just wanted
everyone to have a nice time I didn't
want to have a wedding
why
um because I didn't I think at the end
of the day really want to get married I
did in that moment but fundamentally I
think from the trauma that I had as a
kid I didn't and then I think I told
myself that I did and I I take the full
responsibility of that narrative Kelsey
filed for divorce from Morgan in August
2022. it was finalized that October I
thought that I had my entire life
figured out like I thought that I knew
exactly what love was and what I
contributed to a relationship and what I
needed out of a relationship and I
didn't but once it came down to
splitting assets things got complicated
and Kelsey says she had to make a big
sacrifice can you articulate to me that
I have like a choice right now to either
give up half of a house that I bought
that I bought and he contributed but not
not equal
and
or say legally in this marriage and have
like public alimony hearings
indefinitely
and they're like that's correct and I
was like give them the house I went out
I went out get me out I think I'm losing
my fear of like was that an overshare
I'm just kind of like that definitely
was an overshare and that's all right
who cares and Morgan's not a fan of his
ex-wife over sharing ahead of her
tell-all interview the Australian singer
shared a statement of his own writing
quote it's really sad for me to see this
person who I spent so much of my life
with and loved with all my heart saying
things that aren't reality and that
leave out what really happened she knows
I'm not the type of guy to speak on
those things publicly if this is what
she needs to heal I hope it helps I'm
not married to him anymore and I don't
need to care about his feelings anymore
right I mean that with all the respect
in the world but his journey is not mine
anymore
foreign